[Music]
they hand me this pack of research today
you know I know we've talked a million
times so I feel like I don't need the
research but the first thing at the top
of the pile was a headshot of yours that
is the handsomest headshot I've ever
seen I've met any male actor look at
that headshot that's the most if I had a
headshot like that I wouldn't be
screwing around in late night telling
the streets I was auditioning for
Zoolander so at that point I guess look
at that guy honestly would you pull that
off
Hey keep cutting to it constantly I
thought this guy was a good director
yeah he's torturing me it's a fantastic
shot a lot of manscaping there right I
don't know you tell us it kind of looks
like it right it looks like going on
there honestly except for God's eggs
keeps coming back because that guy's
attracted to this guy I think it was
looks like they're wearing a cologne in
that show that's what I like so much
about
it does I mean where is the cologne ad
to go with that pretty good me I don't I
don't manicure my nails I I shave with
an old razor without putting the powder
on really I don't wear any what I use I
use a rough stone to shame yeah I just
scratch yeah yeah thanks for pretending
yeah I'm curious you have you and I have
seen each other at school functions
sometimes or over the years yeah you've
got three lovely daughters yeah how are
they how are they doing what are your
kids into what stages are they at right
well there's I got three so they're
they're ten seven and four so I got
three of a kind and it's it's it's great
it's all very good right now we're into
the dog phase right now we're we're in
the process of looking for for a dog
which is is is fun although difficult
and fraught with stress and and and we
screw around around the house I don't
know they're they're they're great kids
they do they find you funny do they do
they think like can you make them laugh
not not particularly I they do little
impersonations of me that they think are
funny really
yeah they do they have a couple of moves
that that for some reason putting my
hands on my hips and and and again
a cop in a little bit of Greg attitude
is is their impersonation of me as if
I'm like a male model but now that I see
that at picture you have yeah I wonder
where they got that poster is in all of
their rooms yeah
the eyebrow I'm trying to teach him the
eyebrow right now they you know I'm
trying to get them get them that thing
they're fascinated with the idea of a
raised eyebrow raised eyebrow and one of
them two of them are flat lines but one
of them can get kind of a dad dad I'm
trying to work on that with them this is
time well spent
you bet and of course and of course if
you really want to teach them well you
do the triple black diamond of facial
tics which is the full scalp slip which
goes a little little something like
right I've been working on the bottom an
ear Platts an ear flap yeah I think I've
perfected what you're talking about
check this
that's cuz hey yeah okay right this is
on let's go
sad about that contest the sad thing is
the winner is the one with lower
self-esteem and it was the one that
spent more of his teenage years
practicing that in the mirror it's a tie
yay whoo we we're both losers either of
our children know how to read